since 1927 when these awards first began
they have been 264 performances
nominated as the best actor of the year
the five performances this year will
stand with the finest as Jake LaMotta a
man whose violent career was only part
of a violent life and who Sue's and
whose success in and out of the ring
were balanced by spectacular failures in
the film Raging Bull Robert De Niro
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
for his performance as a husband and
father who was unable to reconcile his
obsession with military life with the
deep needs of his family in the Great
Santini Robert Duvall
[Applause]
[Music]
for a role which combined the ugliest of
exteriors with the gentlest of souls and
which affirms the essential value of
human dignity in the Elephant Man John
Hurt
[Applause]
as Scotty Templeton a man alienated from
him son and nearly powerless to change
that alienation until his own illness
brings understanding to them both in
tribute Jack Lemmon
[Music]
for his performance as the egocentric
film director who stops at nothing to
achieve his concept of the ultimate
effect in a profession where effect is
everything in the stuntman Peter O'Toole
[Applause]
[Music]
the winner is Robert De Niro
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I forgot my line so the director wrote
them down for me I I want to thank
everyone sister said so often but it's
it's true and it's what can I say
I want to thank Bruno Richard Bruno for
the terrific costumes Frank Warner mrs.
Corman Pete Savage and if Pete wasn't
involved in the film or had he wouldn't
have gotten it started I'm a little
nervous excuse me never would have the
film never would have gotten started my
quest more for the makeup Mary Keats the
late gene Baur trial II Owen and Bob
Irwin Winkler and bob charde off Vicky
LaMotta and all the other wives and Joey
LaMotta even though he's suing us
I hope that settled soon enough so I can
go to go over to his house and eat once
in a while and Mark Martin and Paul
Schrader who wrote the script and of
course Jake LaMotta whose life
[Music]
it's all about Marty Scorsese who
[Applause]
[Music]
gave me and all the other actors and
everyone on the film all the love and
trust that anyone could give anyone and
it's just wonderful as a director and I
want to thank my mother and father for
having me and my grandmother and
grandfather for having them and everyone
else who involved in the film and and I
hope that I can share this with it with
anyone that it means anything to and the
rest of the world and especially all
those terrible things that are happening
and I love everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]